[Music]
[Applause]
hey man I love getting to do that
because Kevin never lets me do that but
thank you for coming to black man I'm
beyond did I just [ __ ] that up a little
bit I [ __ ] up
how's everybody doing tonight yeah
everybody all right have you guys met
Todd stashwick hi everyone hi as my
co-host tonight I'm good I'm just gonna
have a seat I thought there'd be stools
no no waiting tables it's like
bartending I'm having flashbacks to New
York no today's like day yeah yeah two
hours that's fair I know what do you
been up to man um working on a thing
can't talk about right now excellent so
am i Yeah right not a thing I can't talk
about right now similar tozi we can't
talk about right where where might the
people have seen you before
in case they're wondering why there's a
different white guy standing next to me
right explain where you came from where
did I come from
i watch cago Illinois all right I'm a
second city boy ironically I started my
career thinking I was gonna do a sketch
comedy and Sarah alive and half-hours
that comes and I end up just murdering
people a lot on television I die a lot I
wind up with with lead in me or in cuffs
but shows wise most recently I did a
stint on the show called 12 monkeys
[Applause]
what portrayed at first II was a
nefarious warlord and then he became all
squishy teddy bear hero by the end
I've seized Oh spoilers but uh yeah it's
it's now available fee all four seasons
on Hulu some main see know me is black
mask on Gotham yeah I've done a lot of
the nerd shows the Buffy's the Angels
the Star Trek's the supernatural I play
Dracula and a black and white episode of
Supernatural that people still every
Halloween oddly really that that that
episode circles back around every
Halloween oh I thought you meant you had
like black and white face Dracula's
coming up to your door sure cuz you know
how hard it is to act in black and white
I can imagine yeah it's not a drawing
time right now huh blots theatre school
are you and Frank Gorshin yeah the only
ones who figure out but yeah so so I've
done a lot of them the nerd shows which
is which is a heck of a lot of fun
because I myself I am one of that that
is what I consume a lot of yeah what was
your entry vector for nerdom like what
was the first thing you thought you were
a nerd for the first the first nerd show
that I did well that you loved that I
loved as a fan we I'm not a young person
so I would say it wasn't a TV show so if
I was eight years old
in 1977 seeing Star Wars as a child I
was in the theater on the day so that
kind of lit the fuse but I had Planet of
the Apes action figures and Star Trek
action figures and also the the 66 Adam
West's Batman it was it was a big deal
to me that was because I didn't realize
it was a comedy at the time I thought
either did Adam West
neither did it was which is probably why
it worked yeah absolutely
I get he for a minute looked as if he
was in on the joke that show doesn't
work you know it falls apart he's got to
be the straight man sugar in the rain
yeah you have to yeah he and Burt Ward
as well like he's the unsung he's the
unsung hero that show too even though he
was playing hero that we sung a lot
about they did I only think that many
bars are the theme song or else we have
to pay royalties excellent out here
though no no everything's free it's
common villainy oh yeah yeah it's a
wretched hive of
including people ah - right yeah so you
were off shooting something this week
yes yeah yes well I did just come back
from Boston where I was doing a romantic
comedy the general people in it I didn't
but I was playing I was playing I'd like
of coughing's of course I finally booked
like a rom-com and I'm still playing
like a Russian mobster
so yeah it's like I'm not like the guy
like running to the church with flowers
so that she doesn't marry the wrong guy
I'm never that guy I'd be the guy
running to the church with the machine
gun go and stop I kill everybody in room
what if they're running to the church to
stop them from marrying the wrong
Russian mobster that would be I want I'm
gonna write that movie say you should do
that is for you I I went to the gym
which if you know me at all is a thing
that never happens in fact hasn't
happened congratulations thank you it
would didn't go that well
oh wait I think I saw this story yeah so
so I yeah like I went to the I went to
the doctor like six months ago
he's like hey so you're not young true
thank you
the first thing so I know I feel it turn
lady youthful no it was like yeah and
you might have the diabetes and I said
oh [ __ ] Mighty Mite it was like your pre
diet going to oh Prieta you're trending
towards diabetes your training for
diabetes right you put in the work
because you're doing great you're
killing it
yeah you're eating all the sugar yeah
nicely done just you know yeah by the
fistful by December full diabetes yeah
you know which wasn't looking for that
but I'm Christmas you get the sugary
brass ring so he's like you need to
start taking better care yourself I'm
like oh yeah I probably should
especially since keV who usually stands
where you stand as lost like a hundred
pounds that has turned full vegan he's
got his vegan powers activated like he's
doing all that [ __ ] and I'm like are
there more cheeseburgers which feels
weird
given that I'm an old man so I
started dieting and you know whatever it
sucks but it is what it is now and then
it's like well I gotta add some physical
fitness to this [ __ ] like I'm joining a
gym like I'm gainfully employed I have
money in my pocket done
dear mr. Bali does Bally's still do gyms
anymore okay that is how long it's been
to a gym my wife my wife still calls the
machines Nautilus nice I'm like its Jack
LaLanne here is he gonna help me workout
Suzanne Somers Jazzercise yeah so I like
I go into I go into 24-hour fitness and
I'm like hey so I haven't been in a gym
since the Clinton administration uh so
we gotta like start slow and this lady
was like [ __ ] yeah let's go and like we
hit it hard so hard that when I left the
45 minutes of what seemed like
pentathlon training I go and I'm like
I'm feeling a little woozy I should buy
myself like an energy drink or like a
Gatorade or something to get my
electrolytes up which people tell me I
need never heard it before but fine and
I'm standing at the counter to buy an
electrolyte drink and the next thing I
know I'm lying face-up like on my back
staring at the ceiling with like four
trainers standing around me asking me if
I knew what month it was yeah why is it
trivia night totally it was like why why
do I feel so comfortable
I wasn't that comfortable before and
they're like Oh work it out it's great
it's like it's all it takes so B's I got
just get to nap it off Oh should have
told me those in that plane great so
they're like yeah no you passed out like
like for real though like yeah like you
were standing here now you just crumpled
and like we think you hit your head on
the tile floor so uh we're gonna take it
easy do you know what month it is and I
thought it was October and I was right
good
I mean it's one out of 12 you're gonna
pretty much suck
we the odds were pretty darn good at the
very least like I said a month and I
like a giraffe yes it's yes so I've
laughing at your misfortune no it was
great
and then I like I had to call my wife
who like that's the last call you want
to get is hey so I worked at once and
the ambulance is here
you should maybe come and drive me home
from either this place or the emergency
room and she's like I'd rather not the
emergency rooms like me neither
and so they did the [ __ ] like EKG and
they pricked my finger and they did the
blood tests and everything like Oh like
you just like your blood sugar was low
and your blood pressure is low and maybe
you exert yourself too much I'm like
yeah a little bit yeah I think she
thought lost this is how every one of
her workouts ends yeah it's either that
or I turn into a superhero like I
thought I might be back home yeah no you
were in metamorphosis stage yes I'm in
peak physical condition I'm the average
of an Olympic athlete underneath sure Oh
a pillar pounds you got a pill it away
yeah so uh but I went back I did like
after that like garbage day where I you
know why we fall down so that trainers
can ask you a month it is I was pulling
it back to the to the back so we can get
back up again back on the rack or no
stretch you in ways you're not supposed
to stretch no I I have I work out at
this lovely place called hero's journey
fitness yeah and they what's his sort of
apropos they they do nerd themed
workouts Christy black and David net and
so and they also destroy you it's like
it's a cute little thing like it's
called walk into Mordor and you're like
no it's an hour of squats like Oh walk
into Mordor well because one doesn't
simply walk though someone will suddenly
walk into Mordor after squats for an
hour yeah simply can walk oh you cannot
you cannot it is about doom but so so
they so I don't know who your trainer
was and we men want to outright I
there's an APB for her she actually
wasn't working there and then she
started dealing like a dance the end but
I did go back I've been back four times
did what I've been back four times since
this all of this hurts all the time
means you're doing it right yeah
because at some point I want to be an
actor and I hear you have to do that
[ __ ] like every day it's all maintenance
no there's no trying out to done I have
to like it's kind of like as a kid where
that your mom wants you to eat broccoli
so she coats it in Cheez Whiz
that's what hero's journey is for me
it's like I get tricked into like oh
you're playing John Williams music all
right I'll do push-ups to that and so I
it coats it in in a nerdy rapper so I
have a good time while I'm miserable
yes I am not so maybe I should think
about that it's fun yeah yeah it's a
great place no I'm sure it's fun come on
it is whatever my guy friends who like
nah man if I don't work out in the
morning I feel like [ __ ] all day
like what no no I had to do I had to do
I had to do like like kettlebell
deadlifts today and I like three o'clock
I am just asleep like it's like oh my
body goes to stop everything I could be
typing and the head would be hitting the
keyboard like you need to stop and
rebuild well yeah no I'm a mess
but you know what I did to sort of
reverse the the trend of working out
whiskey no I watched a lot of television
and movies Oh segue pretty much I went
from like I'm gonna work out a lot of do
[ __ ] that's active to sit here on his
[ __ ] couch like it and watch his
Apple TV [ __ ] see what they got I've you
know you but it feels better knowing
that you've put the work in that's why I
like working out at like 7 o'clock in
the morning so that anything after that
is just my time I just I have no
problems playing video game I think that
I'd gone 47 years without ever having to
have something to get to my time just it
having been my time truth I remember it
like was four years ago I got like
wrinkles on my elbow youngster
I got spring [ __ ] chicken who's been
out in the Sun for 47 years I did see
some [ __ ] this weekend no you did okay
did you did you watch any of the Apple
TV offerings did anybody else watch
anything on Apple TV which was like free
for a weekend and they're gonna take
your kidney no we watched we watched
Watchmen
so not Apple TV ah are you caught up on
the watch man we are caught up in the
watchman I am I'm here for the space
dildo show my god right it looked like a
spaceship from like a Mel Brooks movie
yeah
like first it's like oh I've just got
this bong here ready and vanish like oh
it's got another piece but she also
considered a unless you went yeah it's
like I could do this thing yeah it feels
difficult everybody watch they really
caught up on watch me before we spoil it
too much all right
good some not so much over here well
okay Wow we're I guess well much I'm
just going to say that I am I'm still
shows filled with spoilers we could not
be at the wrong place because we're
gonna be talking about movies we can
meet we can be gentle we'll be gentle as
Laurie Blake compliant unlike that the
Jays and dildo yeah yeah no man it's not
really dr. Manhattan what too soon no
it's good okay I'll give you that
Thanks I I'm still in love with with
Watchmen and I'm in love with it all the
more so because even in episode three
it's decided that it's not gonna be the
show we thought it was going to be you
know where suddenly you're just dropping
anchor and a character we haven't seen
before yet
Laurie Blake which if you know anything
about watch man she was so Silk Spectre
- - from the movie who in that one was
like young and somewhat Nordic and now
it's yes but which is amazing yeah as a
vigilante who by the way my wife and I
went to go see Bill Irwin perform when
he was here you know and and and we're
finishing up Legion right now and as we
said right
it's like legions like if David Lynch
and Kubrick said hey let's do a
superhero show and and and we sit down
to watch it and we are massive legion
fans and Dan Stevens and Jean smart sat
down behind us and I just fan Boyd I
just turned around it was like we love
ya Lee nothing so much and then Dan he's
like well then you got to watch Watchmen
because jeans and then I'm like she gets
to go from Marvel to DC when when you're
a designing woman you can do everything
why whatever you want nobody what's a
designing woman in the show's gonna
she's gonna do an IDW show next she
could do lock and key she could do
whatever she wants she oughta get me
Chad Taylor some work yeah just saying
yep so yeah I mean I'm still loving
Watchmen every [ __ ] stitches it's so
good so good I watched for all mankind
have you seen the frock Anya do you know
what it's about nope
for all mankind is is Apple TVs one of
their big shiny debut shows created by
Ronald D Moore of the Battlestar
Galactica Fame I'm a fan you know it's
the the basic idea is what if the
Russians beat us to the moon what if in
1968 were all gathered around TV or 610
or whatever the [ __ ] it was I know
history and and we're all gathered
around the TV do not cast out I did
literally like three weeks
we may have to remember that I don't
know what month it is what clearly
what's history is like icy railed I'm
providing seeds in a garden you'll never
see I'm ripping off Hamilton I know so
yeah it's what happens to the national
psyche if we don't go to the moon first
well what happens to NASA what happens
to the space race what happens to how we
view ourselves what happens to our at
least what was in the 70s and 80s and
even early 90s obsession with the future
and space and exploration and going
there what happens if all of that gets
stripped away what how's it good it's
pretty great okay
it's pretty great and enough can you
tell which ones are the Cylons yes you
know how
the back slide slide oh and they're fun
they're getting busy yeah and there is
so much [ __ ] on this show really no
no Apple don't let nobody do nothing
really it is it is a very pg-13 ish kind
of like the whole network the whole
network because their whole their their
mantra was we want to be able to put
these on in the Apple stores while
people are buying Apple [ __ ] and we
can't just have like but making it asses
doing [ __ ] well you and your kid or
trying to buy an iPad Wow although that
might move some I'm saying I'm saying
pleasantly surprised because I just I
just upgraded to the to the the new
iPhone and turned on the Apple TV is
like you get a year for free so I'm like
oh that's lovely that's why they're
gonna win yeah they're gonna win they're
gonna win like that apples hurting yeah
in this whole streaming wars it's like
oh yeah Apple that has like 250 trillion
dollars like spare change then I got I
got a spender they get so like helping
the housing crisis mm-hmm - so they they
have the gross national product of a
small country to do and they don't have
to like do the any of the [ __ ] that a
country has to do if they'd like pay for
police or like infrastructure they just
have to remove the home button yeah
that's it like to sell dongles you can
plug your [ __ ] headphones back here
[ __ ] I I swear to God like I all I
want is like my iPhone 6 back with like
an iTunes that worked and I got real hot
I don't care like it keeps you warm in
the winter man sterile from flooding in
my front pocket I got two kids I'm
worried it's the cheapest vasectomy you
can get and it rolls but I have I have a
burn mark on my thigh it's an
identification mark thank that tell them
no but it's their logo I think they did
it on purpose
[ __ ] yeah yeah tattoo they [ __ ] right in
the ass you want to see it all depends
on how much of a dude slash lady boner
you have for Jason Momoa because there's
a lot of him grunting and like covered
in [ __ ] mud okay and just like
everything's dog and then he does like
you know the [ __ ] like the the the
Pacific Islander like the we're duel
yeah we're doing a lot of [ __ ] haka
[ __ ] oh and like but but they're in the
Pacific Northwest they weren't like
Vancouver fair enough and it's like nine
hundred years in the future okay but he
remembers that [ __ ] from and he's the
only one that seems to be he keeps it
alive he keeps it alive that's his job
he is he's fair of the truth he's not a
haka keeper he's the hockey keeper not
the trapper keeper but it's it is one of
the most expensive shows that I've seen
that also looks a lot like the 100 yeah
and like horizon zero dawn yes which is
a better like if you guys haven't played
horizon zero dawn it is the best like
Wyden I oppose just make that show they
should right we should call Apple hang
on
if I only had a device yeah now team
Apple hello I'd like to speak to the
head Apple please mr. Macintosh yeah
McDonald's like he actually has the desk
he's gonna tie but he's got a big an
Apple head hello want to speak to the
Golden Delicious I'm imagining that
every executive has some like codename
Apple name yes I'm the Honey Crisp yes
she's cute so yeah listen if you if you
have Apple TV for free by all means
watch see I'm interested in the Jennifer
Aniston it looks sort of Sorkin asked in
the Matt Lauer show that's the one it
looks it looks sore kinian
sorry sort sir Kinion Kennish sort
kiddush so can i likes our kid again I
like that too yeah done I - I'm a fan of
all things or kinian I'm not sure I will
tune in for the morning show I'll give
it a go no case again it's free that's
how they get you don't cost nothing if I
had to pay it a single red cent for any
of this I'm not sure I would right
except for for all mankind but free yeah
freeze the best price you're pricing I
will take I have that I mean right now
you know I'll get every free with me
I'll give you an author's you need it
yeah I got it I got all the free you
need oh yeah I watched the first two
episodes of
Castle Rock season two okay
which I knew nothing about it in I'm
invested in because I I have I I spilled
some blood in that particular mud the
first season yes sorry I know the people
I like the world I had nothing to do
whatsoever with the season with season
two so it's all a surprise for me okay I
knew they were doing Annie Wilkes that
much I knew and that's uh that's a Lizzy
Caplan Lizzy Caplan is playing well I
did a pilot with I want to say seventeen
years ago
with Jared Padalecki a 17-year old Jared
Padalecki and a very young Lizzy Caplan
as well
Wow but yeah you know I hope things work
out for both of them you know I hear
those kids they got talent
I got potential I'm serious all they
need is one lucky break yes and they
have a swimming pool filled with like
Scrooge McDuck money that they like I
quite I quite liked the first couple of
Castle Rock Co guy who's I've not seen
Castle Rock season one shame on me
that's okay no I know but I did watch
the i watch first episode of what is
that's it yeah which one is this is that
the Prince show is that the batshit
crazy crazy jazz hands and pirate show
the Prince show I'm thinking like Maya
Rudolph have a damn amazing I know can
we get her to do pink do you live the
life deluxe of all time because it beats
nothing so yes and we're back one-one if
you're interested in scary [ __ ] you
should absolutely watch the Castle Rock
some gun to if you like that Kathy Bates
misery you should absolutely watch
Castle Rock season okay Lizzy Caplan is
killing it I auditioned for that season
but I think Tim Robbins got that part he
did yeah I'm sorry so yeah because I had
a shot
[Laughter]
well it's like they just want to burn my
gas
what are you doing today you want to
drive someplace sure we're gonna give it
to Tim Robbins all right
we just won four see if you're off bug
cheater for safety yeah
he's ready like I was the thing that
they were dangling over him gone look
you don't take this deal we got
stashwick in the wings we got stache but
he's like oh whoa I better tell you get
then sorry let me climb through my
Oscars he's fine
you'd have been better he's fine oh come
on I'm a fan nah Roberts sure yeah yeah
shank
a Jacob's Ladder I guess ladder yeah
yeah you know for kids right told the
wacky circumference the hugger bro just
referencing yeah so he said you know
four kids having some I ratified the
movie that we already reference yeah
I heart you so bad I'll hurt you so much
honey this is the player's hand like the
trampy a fighter's handbook yeah yeah
yeah I bleed a lot of nerd blood yeah
yeah whoo there it is I blew sucker
you're welcome tattoo talked with Todd
yeah it's got three T's so that is it so
I was thinking about starting a podcast
and I was like do I call it Todd cast
ooh do I call it
Todd stache cast like there's so many
variations I put it out to the Internet
and I forget what one Todd's talk time
that's [ __ ] on Todd's Teflon paper
yeah dad's tech talk time nope but
anyway I did what we were talking about
um you saw Dez did I a film a film in
film to take away TD called Jo Jo rabbit
Oh Jo Jo Jo the Jo Jo did you see it I
did see it I saw it by myself in the
theater like crying oh yeah it uh it
kicked me in the chest
it was it's as I said as moonrise
kingdom with Nazis yeah it had a lot of
a head a lot of like Wes Anderson feel
to it but normally don't
Wes Anderson I don't even know who you
are I don't Wes Anderson films always
feel like like artisanal cinema like the
marmalade that you'd buy from like Whole
Foods of movies yeah
but like I'm not like mac and cheese guy
like I don't I don't know just Mac and
I'm not just making cheese but his
movies are filled with mansions
ironically his films remind me a lot of
Stanley Kubrick's films which is that
there's there is a level to which it
seems to squeeze out most emotion
interesting favor of this sterility
that's beautiful and gorgeous and I also
find them very funny and very very often
it's cumulative where they're suddenly
that the film will just turn on a moment
and then they destroy me there's a great
moment in you know Royal Tenenbaums by
the end of the film there's this just
moment with Ben Stiller and gene Hackman
and Ben Stiller just goes I had a rough
year dad and then he Ching hai just cuz
I no chance and like I'm just a mess but
but back to Joe Joe ray yes and so I can
absolutely see that that comparison
because you know tyka as at least in
this film is very careful about the
world he's building and the things he's
putting in that world and the casting of
these characters he was himself was
channeling Michael Palin yeah as Hitler
he's going he's going hard for Hitler
and and what a line you have to walk
like what a goose step well it what a
yeah it was come on right I mean if
we're gonna write it's right you
couldn't resist I know I'm just low
hanging fruit so but invented the and
then the so just just not to bring
things down too much but I recently lost
my father
and there's that Kirill key quote at the
end of the film
which is I'm gonna butcher it now but it
was it was it's like it's like go
through everything the beauty and the
terror because feelings are always
on the move and and that's sort of the
process of grieving because there's a
lot of what this boy is going through
and and I was just like I was just in
the movie theater trying not to call all
the attention to myself as I'm just like
thanks for my wife and she's giving me
the reassuring shoulder squeeze as
support but I'm like I can't move
because I'm just a puddle it and at the
same time one of the funniest movies
I've seen it's insanely fun alone and
the last the last shot of the movie is
maybe the most joyous thing I've seen in
forever because it's so simple and it's
so gorgeous and it starts to sneak up on
yes yet earned and totally totally like
everything in this movie is both set up
and paid off in ways that are haven't
settled as well it's an uncommon film
not an easy thing to pull off and it is
done with such grace and reverence and
at the same time really irreverent and
really funny and and and I think the
Scarlett Johansson's best work to date
yeah she's phenomenal the scene when she
I don't want to give too much away but
when she puts the beard on I'm like this
is a fantastic and the shape of that
scene was just exquisite yeah yeah it's
it's it's Tiger riding a line that's in
kind of elevating his work and like I
love Thord I love and I love what we do
in the shadows but he's like jumped a
level with with this film and I did see
one other movie it'll be the last movie
we talked about if you get into them yes
terminator dark fate nobody else that's
Johnny back there yeah how'd it had it
how did you guys feel about said
Terminator hoon film we're getting the
devil horns over here we're down to the
laws we got a thumbs out we're gonna get
clapping yep
guys little immense immense over there I
feel like more people were in line with
the men's immense than everybody else I
quite liked it I did too
I quite liked it it's it's got some flab
to it and it's got
but it's a grilled-cheese like I know
what I'm in for right like it's me it's
going like I it really is just kind of a
reskin of the other two not the other
five but the other two you know it seems
as if there is only really one
Terminator movie that was necessary yes
which is the first one yes the second
movie is a remake of the first one we
had a little bit of a gloss yes and but
when short things like I'm no longer
playing villains yeah you make zero now
I'm not gonna shoot anybody my gonna
kill anybody like I'm gonna give a
thumbs up to the dude at the end
everybody wins yes this movie is again a
remake of that first movie which is
here's a woman who is apparently crucial
to the future of the resistance against
some enemy that was born of artificial
intelligence and somebody will come
along and save her from you know
backwards through time and yeah like you
know what that story kind of is you know
- so there's like there's a couple of
like twists on the theme oh yeah okay
well it was a different way of doing the
thing that we expected but for the most
part it it hits all the notes in it so
and they're executed very very well yeah
yeah there's nothing in this movie that
feels like half-assed no but the
question is do we need more Terminator
and I don't I think the answer the
question so we're good right yeah which
it was a Genesis I did not see it I saw
half of it well lit a Hamilton yeah and
there there's something wonderful about
this movie being about fundamentally
these three women yes sort of dealing
with their responsibilities - and for EM
because over the future yes and that's
kind of lovely and and that level of
kind of awareness yeah has always been
in the Terminator movies like it's not
like it's some brand-new thing that they
decided we're gonna be like woke
terminator no until you remember they're
lookin Eider woken a day the like thus
good second movie was like oh no it's
Linda Hamilton and like kind of a half
latina kid and a black dude and an
Austrian tree saving the world yes and
the first movies about this young woman
I'm saving the world yes so it's always
been baked into this story but it's just
like how much of that does one need and
I seems as if at least according to the
box office which made twenty one nine
million dollars opening weekend it cost
a hundred eighty to make it needed it
will need to limp its way to something
like four hundred million dollars so
I'll just see it
eight hundred more times somebody's
gonna have to because it's not gonna do
that by itself and so worldwide it's a
bit of a fluff domestically it's a bit
of a flop well and what what what do you
think that is I think some of it is is
fatigue I think some of it is it came at
the end of a year that was filled with
franchise stuff I think that despite
they we brought Arnold back we brought
Linda Hamilton back that there's just a
there's an exhaustion for this franchise
and maybe there'd been three or four too
many of them I was a terminator you were
I was on the television show I was which
which I was killed by an elevator friend
of the show Zak stents was a writer
producer well on terminated the Sarah
Connor Chronicles yeah and I think there
might have been exhaustion then there
might have been but you know at least
that that show was doing interesting and
new and different things with the summer
while someone who's fantastic you know
all things with Summer Glau are great
yep
well yeah like I just think that maybe
this is an idea whose time has come and
gone sad as it might be to say because I
like that world and I like I like Sarah
Connor
I like Aaron Arnold was was lovely in it
it is you know an interesting evolution
of that idea of that character and and
and if you take about and so many of the
themes were about immigration and and
and and how something that is fixed in
its ways as it's exposed to humanity can
change its mind yeah hmm I mean it was a
nice like timely take on an idea totally
um although a lot of watching Arnold
make me hunk made me hungry for Conan
the King like I want
be like agent Conan the Barbarian Oh
the Unforgiven of guys that up because
now they're talking Last Action Hero 2 I
mean they were yeah I saw that in the in
the in the train in the trades
I'm all for be like the one last ride
for all of these old action heroes who
just like imma do all my Rambo's and
rocking [ __ ] I'm a closeout all of my
own watch like a [ __ ] and like Mel
Gibson will make another Lethal Weapon
I'm sure whether we wanted her not raver
heart braver heart gets killed at the
end but somehow he's covered like he
stops the blade yeah freedom let's go
yeah yeah no all of that [ __ ] so yeah
and I'm all for that like I as a pure
nostalgia hit give me those things I
left as a kid yeah again I want to see
John matrix one last time yeah yeah yeah
predators all right that is all we have
about the [ __ ] that we saw yeah
that means it's time for the news let's
do it that means it's the time for when
I cut and paste [ __ ] from the internet
and then put them in a document and then
read them okay you ready for this oh you
know what I don't know and that's what's
interesting
yeah you don't know I don't know if I'm
ready you know I may be completely
unready for it I'm gonna break you and I
will be broken and it will be witnessed
yeah there's cameras here yeah you will
witness my breaking I kill Todd
stashwick
with the news you're welcome yep
TV we'll have to find another villain
that was the new sound yeah we had all
like news there's like a new Sorkin -
it's like Rocky Horror now it's very
interactive they're gonna whip toes v
Bobby McFerrin in the crowd like putting
together a [ __ ] news feed speaking of
Bill Irwin yes but you don't worry being
hazed in the video so so you know
they're making another Batman movie
right
okay sorry are you interested in that
yeah I believe I bleed for Batman yeah I
love the Batman
ah so yeah they're making another one I
can't wait and they're casting yes they
are do you do you know who they cast
today
why is really today why no mark I'll
pretend like I don't excellent news what
news they cast Colin Farrell Colin
Farrell Colin Farrell young young what
Colin Farrell with young feels young
well sure I'm a fan
nobody skincare regime is him ridiculous
he's never in the Sun no and he's got
great hair anyway he's playing the
penguin which is nice uncommon did not
see that kind of I would have I would
not have seen that coming
i I prefer it to the Jonah Hill
conversation like a month ago because I
kind of like I don't mind Jonah Hill
will see what see what that means that's
what I'm saying like what does it what
does the the writer/director have in
mind when they got he's the best choice
for this it'll be faster yeah I wonder
if they got like the Lee Adama fat suit
from Battlestar Galactica or like listen
we're gonna cast a skinny dude but we're
gonna go fat Lee Adama with this [ __ ]
right yeah it's gonna [ __ ] like Colin
Farrell and a giant stay Pokemon OB that
will be I mean it's list he's gonna like
Jake LaMotta and like put on wait for it
or it's just a complete reinvention of
the pink wall maybe he just really likes
to eat but he also works out a lot yeah
yeah he really is also with evil evils a
thinning agent as we saw in the Joker
yes totally so yes he is playing the
penguin and they got an Alfred as well
yes in the circus I'm a fan I'm a fan
[Applause]
yeah so this thing is just dripping with
Brits it is driven with Brits and I and
I also it's clear that Matt Reeves
enjoyed working with Andy Serkis
on the plan of the Eames moving up it
was like you know what buddy now when
you show your mocap it and still look
like Michael Caine
that CGI Michael Caine but circus was
gonna is gonna do
call it The Imaginarium thinking of
Michael Caine slight digression you know
what else I did this weekend I went to a
live reading of a screenplay written by
Brian Kavon called round table are you
familiar with the round table screenplay
no it he wrote in 2008 it was on the
blacklist back then a very early
blacklist script
uh-huh and it's about I just can't wait
to see how this has to do with Mike okay
well
Morgana LeFay only the author in legends
has returned to modern-day London and
it's attempting 3,000 Kenneth mm but
Merlin now living in in Brooklyn because
he's that's where you go cuz it's hip
that's where you go
his face was have a dog-walking business
he likes to play like World of Warcraft
and [ __ ] but so faced with the task of
having to round up new Knights to do
battle with Morgan Olaf a turns to the
Knights of the realm as they exist today
which are in this moot in this
screenplay a a grocery store magnate a
retired soccer player okay a
herpetologist this is in comedy yes
okay who's done great work with newts
okay and Sir Michael Caine love it it is
the funniest loving it's awesome and so
the blacklist had a live reading over
the weekend with Tony Hale playing
Michael Caine with Jay Pharoah with
taran killam playing Merlin Vanessa
Rothschild from insecure playing Morgan
le Fay it was phenomenal
what a tree two hours of joy what a
treat so yeah you'll never get to hear
it or see it anywhere they're never
gonna make it
they're never gonna make it damn it
although I wish they would well Michael
Caine is still alive just we can play
Mike rain reminding people that he was
in Jaws the revenge in the in the film
itself yes he pulls out of Jaws revenge
reference a hair family damn it yeah
so yes anyway it would be great if Andy
Serkis was mo capping as Michael Caine
that's that's that's how we got back to
that that's how we got the segue back to
the main highway but the scenery was
beautiful
in it though so nice no uh-uh so yes
Matt Reeve is writing directing it is
due out I think in 2021
they start production well they're
actually making it oh they're actually
no not round table same the Batman well
back to Batman that's all right back oh
you missed this get on the [ __ ]
highway we're back we're back you're
right you're right I was looking at man
I can't I know we're back
so 2021 is the release 2021 is it
release I'm all for all the casting that
has come out on that so far from the
Riddler and Commissioner Gordon and it's
Catwoman yeah yeah yeah I'm all for it
all for it as long as I get to get the
play hush that's it that's all I want
just put out there in the world
Manchester broadcast apparently they're
gonna give it to Tim Robbins but ya know
he's all about it he's all about he's
gonna he's gonna start working out yes
hero's Qi fitness see lots of Jacob
Clemens come on to him you could doesn't
I'm gonna have a Jacob's Ladder work and
do Jacobs ladders in it yeah are you
familiar with a podcast slash twitch
streaming thing called critical role
very much yes
critical role if you are not familiar at
home it is a podcast that has been sort
of created to document and chronicle the
journey of like a dozen voice actors
who've been running themselves through a
D&D campaign for about like three or
four or five or ten years unclear if
they started like in there in there like
living room playing D&D so it was a
natural evolution of and somebody said
you know be fun we should just stream
this totally like guess what it was fun
it was fun it was very popular they
started a Kickstarter about a year and a
half of them liked to do uh they wanted
to make a 30-minute adaptation of one of
their baby like campaign episodes they
were asking for $750,000 which sounds
like a king's [ __ ] ranch answer who
asks for that holy [ __ ] like I gotta pay
yeah they got eleven million dollars
eleven million dollars eleven million
dollars
so rather than just make their one half
an hour episode lit they went to Amazon
and Amazon was like [ __ ] you guys seem
popular we should make like two seasons
of this show we'll take your 11 million
dollars and add it to our 14 billion
dollars and we'll make two seasons of an
animated show okay and so that news
broke today that that I'm like it's like
you're walking in with your 11 million
and they're like and Amazon's like look
at them put there a little bit of money
that is Jesus is just eating a salad of
thousand-dollar bills yeah keep it in a
bank maybe gets an interest yeah use
them as napkins that's fine you know you
need kindling it gets cold and easily
wrinkles you don't have good insulation
in your house right do that good
but yeah so they're there they're up and
running now titmouse is the animation
house yeah and if you're not familiar
with titmouse they also do Venture
Brothers and yes that one that you said
Jim my food yes as far as part of the
70s family the other animated thing that
made me so excited this week
yep spider-verse - got a release date
right if if you don't know the the first
spider-man into the spider-verse was my
number one movie of last year kinda
great it's my daughter lost her mind
that's her favorite spider brands
[ __ ] stuff it's miles is her favorite
spider-man yeah you know you know I I
saw that movie five times in the theater
yeah and I I can't remember having done
that in like 20 years well I'll just
I'll put my [ __ ] money I will watch
this again
again and again I didn't see endgame
that much in the theater I went three
times I went I went maybe black panther
I saw like four times but spider-verse
was I got to find new people to take
with me you just keep throwing your
money at Marvel yep I love this have you
guys this is yeah do you guys know what
the shows about
so so okay we're gonna take a detour yes
spider-man spider-man in spite of verse
two got a release date April 8th 2022
yeah I did hear I did yeah well come
back but I did hear that the Japanese
spider-man might be in spider-verse I
think I said right that's amazing
but but you're so excited the one thing
I'm less excited about that Peter Ramsey
is not or none of the directors from the
original coming back why well I said
like Chris Walken why I unclear unclear
they may or may not be producers on it
the guy who's directing this is Joaquin
dos Santos okay who was one of the
instrumental directors behind avatar and
Korra
oh those okay when I was at banshees no
yes the other yes avatar and The Legend
of Korra and I love those two series so
much everybody on those hello no wrong
yeah yeah yeah so yes I don't think it's
not in bad hands but it's like oh man I
miss those guys who won an Oscar for
making that is Lord and Miller Lloyd
Miller are still producing but I don't
know how much more they're doing than
that yes
so Martin Scorsese and Marvel he did an
interview with Empire magazine for the
Irishman probably bout a month ago where
he said and has been quoted somewhat out
of context Marvel movies are ruining
cinema as we know it
I'd to watch one couldn't make it all
the way through I don't understand it
it and it came across very much as like
old man shouts at sky yeah for rain
coming
he then just yesterday wrote an op-ed
for the New York Times sort of
explaining what that was like further
going further and like yes that was
taking someone out of context but his
position is it is not so much that I
don't think these are movies as we know
it I think that the problem is is that
Marvel movies and franchise pictures are
crowding the cinemas to the degree that
you can't actually if you're a young
filmmaker an independent filmmaker or
the kind of filmmakers that Martin
Scorsese grew up loving and being sort
of contemporized and influencing and
influencing could not find a way to
their movies into actual theatres the
movie companies were not making movie
like that anymore
so he was lamenting the fact that you
couldn't go and discover the new you
were only given more of the same right
and it's like okay no that's a valid
point that yes the the business is
shifted to the degree where most of what
we get on the big screen is a very
specific kind of thing which is we know
it's going to make money and a lot of
these sort of mid budget movies like
would have been Goodfellas like would
have been you know the Godfather like
would have been anything targeted at
adults has shifted off of the big screen
or onto the small screen and that's what
it was
or independent or independent but
there's also less movie theaters that
are in the business of showing you
movies yes and the small art houses are
kind of faded away and so yes there was
absolutely only so he's not wrong in
saying that it changed the landscape of
cinema as we know right
they say destroyed it he doesn't say it
destroyed it okay but he says that like
he felt bad for the young artists today
who grew up wanting to make movies big
and having those movies exhibited the
way that movies right in his eyes should
be exhibited witches in the dark on a
big screen with a hundred people around
you but the television in its heyday now
yes television has taken a sum of that
like we're making grown-up stories and
it's become Breaking Bad it's become
better call Saul then Mad Men it's
become all of these amazing shows no one
loved yes but he is just lamenting what
was for him yeah the I can go and see a
new Spike Lee movie and be surprised and
shocked and amazed by what I get every
time yes
and yet we thought Jojo rabbit last
weekend like there's always kind of
going to be space for that yeah but that
is they're all shrink they all get
nominated for Oscars it's it's the like
it's the the november/december prestige
yes that every studio will make one or
two movies that are destined to run for
Oscars yep few will win because there's
only one of each thing they're gonna
break out but it becomes like it's part
of the business the campaign is part of
what makes those things go but there's
less and less of those and every now and
again you'll see a movie like that that
gets released in like March and it just
dies
on the vine because nobody wants it
because there's a [ __ ] Captain
America movie comes like earlier this
year there was a film called fast color
which I talked about yeah sort of at
length on the podcast which I love to
death love love loved it made almost no
money in the theater it had got a
theatrical run of one week in like New
York in LA and a couple of theaters in
the middle of nowhere probably Chicago
which not the middle of nowhere I
understand my bad
but it was in the theaters for a week
and at the end of that week end game
came out an end game swallowed every
available screen from sea to shining sea
and so yeah like it's harder for the new
and different to get any purchase in
traditional theatrical exhibition but
like surfer dude like sir yes my magnum
opus yes so that that has been the big
sort of Martin Scorsese V Marvel V like
old versus young and to a certain degree
it is absolutely his right to be a 75 /
80 something-year-old man who doesn't
quite get what the kids like because
that's the job of being an old man and
being the kids like you're not supposed
to like what the kids like and the kids
aren't supposed to like what you like
well so good play but when other sort of
filmmakers began to like rally behind
him and this is the other pylon is what
was and then and in his and his op-ed is
was thoughtful and it was totally but
the pylon was just ridiculous
yeah so I will still wear the shirt
because I think it's funny it's very
funny
I need more t-shirts oh yeah yeah yeah I
can imagine that your wife is like no
you don't need more t-shirts
I need more house because to contain
it's a sad truth I think at one point I
had 55 Star Wars t-shirts something to
that effect yeah that makes sense yeah
I'm not proud proud of I'm a goblin are
you are you a Game of Thrones fan I am
you are I did watch all of the game of
throne
are you excited we're going to get new
Game of Thrones uh was that a loaded
question you know my TV time is very
limited uh-huh and so unless I find out
like there's great TV that I still
haven't seen mmm that I want to see that
is from years back that Columbo for me
that you're so good and she did right
murder and killed so many it's so true
yeah so there's they're such great TV
that like I'm not caught up on that so
like I got very sated I'm actually more
excited about Witcher okay cuz it feels
a little more magic II a little more D&D
like I think there was I mean Game of
Thrones was what it was and and there
were moments like come on we're magic
and we're monsters because I'm just like
a nerd boy like that but I did really
enjoy Game of Thrones I don't know if I
will run at a sequel or a prequel unless
I hear it's amazing well we're
definitely getting a prequel so I'm told
not the prequel we thought we were gonna
get no because they were shooting a
prequel called the long night yes that
they are not shooting anymore it was
like 24 but yeah when is he gonna take a
leak where's that drink yeah yeah I put
a socket Chloe caught the ig-88 heads
it's pretty cool right yeah that's
really cool anyway yeah no they were
shooting one called a long night
apparently the pilot that they shot
wasn't that good HBO didn't like it HBO
thought they didn't like the first never
thrones pilot they don't they seem to
have a track record of making shitty
game of Thrones pilots that that they
can either rescue in some fashion by
throwing more money and time at it or
abandoning it which is the case with a
long night and so they've then shifted
their focus from that one what's
supposed to be like the age of here
like tens of thousands of years ago your
high Valyrian and all the door to the
house of dragons which is about the
Targaryen so and it is not quite and
they're super early distant it is more
like a couple hundred years before the
war all ending up to the Targaryen Civil
yeah yeah yeah and presumably you would
see the birth of baby Daenerys Targaryen
oh it's that recent I think it's so it's
like just like twenty three years before
I think yeah I mean I'm gonna be sure I
don't know but there will be dragons as
called house of dragons well I'm sayin
see you want a muscles that give you
drive I want like like the Rick wearing
suits there's just so many dragons it's
like morning dragon morning like dragon
technically coyote yeah Fred Oh morning
[ __ ] I was the dragon in today I don't
know go to war with dragon and in the
West 4000 coats are out there you can
eat them real easy
fresh meat on the hoof you snored it me
a little bit yeah so and george RR
martin is being particularly sanguine
about it which is like you know it's
always a long road and i'm i'm busy
writing a book you guys is that the
problem getting that type done for the
day you guys into Yes Mother
I wrote a word today I don't know why
yeah I decided that his significant
other is called mother but he's British
yeah today dragon very exciting you
don't going to go far a little George
next week more words more words
yeah so he won't have a ton to do with
house of dragons because they never tug
to do with the current one no by the
time they got to the end they just ran
out of but he did write like an episode
of game I was like I don't know if I'll
do it this time but but Ryan Condal who
did a colony among other things on the
televisions he's is the showrunner and
Miguel's Apache Nick who directed many
of the hugest episodes of Game of
Thrones oh cool the battle the bastard
doctor Battle of Winterfell like
anything in battle in the title he's a
he's the dude that they called was like
we gotta shoot for like 55 days at night
in the cold you're our guy Miguel okay
tell my children I love them
he's also British Game of Thrones yeah
speaking of British [ __ ] they're making
another fantastic beasts movie yes wait
yes
hold on explain to me why the yes though
because like no but I mean hey listen
different strokes I mean the first one
was kind of Pokemon listen kind of
Pokemon like gotta catch them all if you
told me that these movies were like the
daring adventures of gay Dumbledore [ __ ]
yes Amen all day
amen like that dude just [ __ ] people
in other countries with magic hell yes
like Jude Law in his most like Bowie
just like swatting through the past with
like magic and tweed suit with a with a
Phoenix on his shoulder yeah have a
strut nice step
yep hey man I'm in [ __ ] yes no it's not
that though there's beasts which are
fantastic maybe occasionally a hero that
accidentally wins at the end yeah why
sure she's got a suitcase full of [ __ ]
that always goes wrong platypus succeeds
yes
I will say in this one is taking place
in Rio de Janeiro as you do as you do
and like I at least like the fact that
they're there they're being
international with it is Depp coming
back don't know oh you guys haven't
talked about it uh yeah me and me and
Johnny you and John I thought we talked
about you and Jack we talked about we
talked about men's cologne hangout and
guitars and guitars and like an RIS
Twitter should we form a rock band Jenny
he's like very good yes let's let's do
it can you play anything no no me
neither
let's go Wow Sauvage I write when I'm
when I'm not on a show I often write in
food courts because I like hey I like to
be around people when I'm writing I like
like the constant buzz of chatter sure I
like the people watching life life
around you and amongst you yes in the
mall that I write hiring there's a giant
[ __ ] banner of Johnny Depp Sauvage
everytime I walk in it's inspiring it's
your totem of power it really is now I
like I like to touch it like I'm an OG
football player as I walk ins that yeah
it's like the Blarney Stone and then
once these I'm assuming they were kids
because kids do this [ __ ] change the V
in Sauvage to an S so it's just sausage
and it made me so happy
just like wordplay graffiti yes like
vandalism with wit and size so yeah I
don't know if he will be in the
fantastic beast through right I'm just
hoping for more [ __ ] like Jude Law
Gabe Dumbledore yeah yeah because it's
so much fun that's the show that I'd
like to see you know or the movie here
Warner Brothers you can spend a hundred
fifty million dollars on this yes it's
gonna be what it is right just make it
come on all right come on commander I
know I reserved
comment okay fair enough just in case
they want to cast you yes yes in the Tim
Robbins role and we're out excellent
that is all the news we have today my oh
what we did it we got through uh Todd's
first news segment
no we did it okay you know what that
means what that means we go on to Q&A oh
there's a spotlight
I like we have we have a litany of
giveaways giveaway we have the most
recent poster from Nate Gonzales like
all these signed by Todd and myself we
need to do this Phil yes when I play you
play Nancy Alan and I play Bible with
Nancy Allen - you're Robocop - you're
Peter Weller yes we got some 40x tickets
have you seen uh have you seen a film in
the 40x before is that where the seats
move yeah oh that is where it'll wet
your pants for you if you're lucky right
cuz if not he'll do other things do you
like Loretta Terry and you're like oh
I'm gonna be myself yeah now it's pretty
awesome it is as I like to call it going
outside for people who don't like to be
outside oh is it that good it's that
good I remember seeing rug one in 40 X
uh-huh and like you know when you're
when you're in the very beginning when
when the bad guy is walking across these
marshy plan phrenic that guy and then
like wind is blowing in the theater and
the seater like a gently moving one of
the rain like a rain so up in the
theater pretty [ __ ] badass it becomes
like super atmospheric and it's like
you're ghost on the movie Wow yeah you
can smell Mads Mikkelsen breath yes it
smells like tacos
oddly oh I love very much tacos
very much made with human meat yes and
so yes Brett Deacon and the good folks
over 40 X offer us these lovely things
to give away there's one in downtown LA
there's one probably in a city near you
if you live in a major city
you should go love it and you know
holiday movie season is coming up it is
I'm gonna have some [ __ ] [ __ ] for
tea yes you should do that I'll see a
star war and we have a giant [ __ ]
Batman
whoa look at that it's almost too heavy
to lift given that I've been to the gym
but inside edition's and DC put together
this Batman 80th anniversary giant
[ __ ] hardcover Jam D it's a beauty
it's a beauty you can use this for
research or home defense yes boom right
umm yeah so three of them I'm gonna help
out here please yeah you look like
you're in shape there and then a gift
bag from the Ripley's Believe It or Not
people it's not a person who can push
their eyes out of their head it's ya
know lyric there's a person in the bag
believe it or not it's the tiniest
person it is Tom Thumb so there we have
it boys and girls the only restrictions
is you have to ask a question that both
Todd and I can answer yes and you know
don't ask for hugs cuz we'll give them
for free oh oh oh yes JC is walking
around he's got a mic hey camper
hello gentlemen how are you good what's
your name filled with my voice Rockwell
knuckles what Rockwell knuckles birthday
just shrugged it works right sure first
off I want to say thank you for allowing
me to stand up here shout out to
everybody here cuz everybody's awesome I
want to say I loved you in the riches or
hey you were great twelve Monkeys
honestly my favorite role you play was
the Cowardly Lion and Tom and Jerry's
The Wiz and the Wizard of Oz you just I
am deep bead me spine-tingling my friend
spine tingle it was so fun I'm just
saying anyway my question is something
simple and I'm being a little selfish
but it will include you also Todd I
mentioned earlier when I bumped into you
that a genius is one of my favorite
comic books I think it's fantastic I
think it's a very well-written comic you
I remember one time on another episode
you mentioned that you would not
compromise on the storyline on a certain
level because they'd be like Oh could it
be a private security team but the other
eye
like no this needs to be the story that
is telling you know the Alexander the
Great of this day an Asian is a black
girl named destiny incredible my
question to you sir is two questions who
would you cast in the main cast of
genius if it was a television show and I
thought my big-budget HBO AMC whoever
Netflix and what role would Todd play
okay all right I wasn't a leave you out
Todd when I leave Todd out I in in the
conversations that we'd had about the
book it was always clear in my mind that
we would cast around the main character
so like you know we would cast Todd
stashwick definitely Tennant gray we
would cast like Queen Latifah as Siobhan
we would cast like cast the big roles
like Giancarlo Esposito can be that guy
and like just just put all of our names
in the supporting cast and then find
somebody break a star do a giant [ __ ]
casting search and find me the perfect
destiny there was there's a heartbeat
where we like you know Amandla Stenberg
might be really interesting in this
because she's like mad talented and
crazy smart and like I believe that she
could pull that off if if given the
opportunity but I still like the idea of
doing a thing that movies don't do that
much anymore which is find me somebody
I've never seen before
and make that part of the story you know
just like who is that girl we've never
met before who is that young woman from
a place we've never been before who just
has the look and has the intensity it
has everything we need it to be and and
and make a star Hollywood you see that
all the [ __ ] time I'd be on ingenue
system like who's that who's that who's
that you know like you watch it for Eve
to quiz Ruth Peter O'Toole's first
[ __ ] movie is Lawrence of Arabia you
know like some casting agent found that
guy just wandering through bars in
London and was like the drunk one get me
that guy and everybody stood up yeah
another drunken no not that one no no no
that was a pretty woman with the blue
eyes would you prefer to be a film or TV
series when when we first thought it up
it was gonna be a movie because at that
time and
life everything was movies and it felt
like that was the sure best destiny
would be a movie pardon the pun but I
think that that today the longer we've
lived with that story the longer we've
actually told that story the more I
think it's probably TV and the more that
I think you can you can dig into it
remember Joss Whedon saying something
like I love movies but only in TV can
you have like the Russian novel
experience which is you're gonna tell
this thousand page story that just goes
and it gets richer and you introducing
characters and you're digging deep you
can't go deep with very much of anything
in a movie because you've got two hours
that's it you're skittering on the
surface but in TV you could just drop
anchor and just excavate character in a
way you can't in the movie so yeah I
think it's I think it's a movie I think
it's let's find somebody lovely and
wonderful and and enshrine somebody new
and then put a bunch of [ __ ] Oscar
nominees and Todd in the supporting cast
I'm all about you Todd cool cool thank
you no thank you man
come come and get your [ __ ] and maybe a
friend to help you carry it I know see I
told you man there's a lot Rock well
good to meet you nice meeting you uh-huh
hey man what's your name John Martin
that was my best Kevin Smith in person
hey man what's your name hey John what
could we do you for so knowing a writer
who is very close who's my task team
what is your what is your favorite
project that didn't get off the ground
for whatever reason either it was you
know didn't get as far as you wanted it
to get didn't get approval didn't get
whatever the the not necessarily
something you have yet to make be loved
and lost moment probably not something
you want to talk about I loved and lost
write something you worked hard you put
your blood sweat and tears into but it
never saw the public domain well I'll
take the mic so I had the good fortune
of spending three years working on a
Star Wars video game that I
was co-writing and then and then ei
pulled the plug on it now
no it was the one that with Amy Hennig
who created Uncharted so I was
co-writing that project and so you know
it definitely is a loved and lost
situation where I I was invited on board
to to help shape the story and write and
I got to live the nerd boy dream I got
to go to Skywalker Ranch and I got to go
through the archives and I worked in
step with with the Lucasfilm story team
and I was really proud of the work and
then as these things do for whatever
reasons they do them that it just didn't
move forward it just they pulled the
plug on the game and so that one that
one broke my heart
pretty pretty hard because you know if I
picked one franchise that is the closest
to my heart it would be Star Wars and
and to be invited into that side of the
velvet rope if you will to be able to at
some point add to the Canon of of this
franchise that I love so much that one
that was the biggest heartbreak there
are others but that's the one that
springs to mind immediately I have to
one was mine and one with somebody
else's that I put quite a bit of time
into and I talked about the first one on
the podcast at one point before but
Kevin and I at one point early on when
we were still doing commentary tracks
for Gotham which didn't last very long
because Gotham sorry it's you know what
I was I was happy to be in Gotham City
hey like that was no truly I mean just
to decide like there was a moment where
we were shooting in the Bronx and it was
like two o'clock in the morning and I
was in a building but like going nope
I'm in Gotham City like according to
Warner Brothers in DC the building I'm
standing in is Gotham City and it
my checks are cut from Wayne National
Bank yes I'll take it I'll take it but
but we hit we had spun out this idea on
the podcast of telling the story of
Alfred having to care for this broken
young boy like Alfred it was supposed to
be like this four-part story chronicling
Alfred's interactions with Bruce Wayne
starting with the day that the Wayne's
die like Crime Alley like Alfred gets
the [ __ ] call you're your benefactors
are dead and there's a ten-year-old boy
in an alley and how Alfred starts to
deal with that kid right and then you
flash forward a little bit and Bruce
Wayne you know still young still broken
and the fact that alfred built a wall
around this child because he doesn't
he's not a parent he doesn't know how
[ __ ] parenting works so he's like I I
want to protect him and my protecting of
him is I'm not gonna send him back to
school I'm gonna get tutors I'm not
gonna force him to go to therapy I just
wanted to be safe and I'm gonna I'm
gonna protect him the only way I know
how I'm a soldier you put him behind the
[ __ ] fence and you you shoot it
everybody wants to come close he doesn't
let the kid heal so he heals wrong he
heals broken and then the third chapter
was Alfred alone in Wayne Manor
when Bruce is off in his life I'm a
learn kung fu and fine [ __ ] faith his
vision question his Vision Quest his you
know his Jesus has lost days where he
goes to figure out how to [ __ ] do
kung fu and [ __ ] and then the last
chapter was the the Alfred reckoning
with the monster that he created every
night like Bruce Wayne goes out comes
back broken Alfred has to stitch him up
and send him back out to the war and
that feeling that that acknowledgment
that I did this I contributed yeah I
made this thing like I took this boy
that I loved and threw like care and
feeding but the raw guy did the best
that I could but I didn't know how to do
it right and the result of that is this
man who tortures himself every night who
breaks bones every night who I have to
patch up and reckon with my guilt about
this every night and so we're like no
that's [ __ ] awesome we should do that
as a comic book like yeah let's [ __ ]
do it as a comic book
so we pitch it to DC and they're like we
don't know
people care that much about Alfred what
you know who cares about Alfred Andy
Serkis Andy Serkis and this was
literally like three or four weeks
before they announced the pennyworth TV
show and I'm like well maybe you should
tell epics cuz they're about to spend
like 75 million dollars making it a TV
show all about Alfred yeah but they're
like yeah it's just marketing isn't sure
that they can get it done and and we
said all right hey it's your IP it's
your like okay cool it's this is your
toy you don't want us to play with
that's fine right unless in that that's
the often the heartbreak when you're
when you're playing in other people's IP
is that is that you're invited to a
party that that isn't yours yeah it's
not your party yeah like any minute they
can turn the [ __ ] lights on and say
everybody go home yeah and I was I was
working on I you know I spent some time
co-writing a version of Suicide Squad -
and and then the business does what it
does and now James Gunn is doing I'm
looking forward to seeing his version
but it's like any time you're playing in
someone else's IP it is so much larger
than you are that it's not like your
idea that you crafted that you go okay
well you don't want it well then I'm
gonna go bring it over here cuz somebody
you know people asked us about both of
those projects they asked me was like
well can't you take it anywhere else
like absolutely not because it's not
mine it's not mine to take and so
especially when you're when you're
investing in developing a pitch for
something it is such a time commitment
to flesh that out and to to walk into
the world of these producers and and and
and go here's what you might want to do
with your thing yeah and it's hard
because you can't file the serial
numbers off like that that's sort of you
know a way of saying just take out the
things that make it Batman
and just tell that story and it's like
it only really
works like yeah you need those touch
stones with the weight of that world
otherwise I then have to tell you what
that man because because we know where
it goes that's also the tragedy of it
right like it only works as the the
tragedy of alpha I think is what we're
gonna call it that's good if you if you
know what happens and you only know what
happens if you understand could you
pitch that as a limited book to DC well
you just did which C yeah that was the
one that that that somebody else had
owned and then there was a pilot that I
wrote like four years ago called Omega
and the idea was the the the pitch was
bond with a wand it was it was it was
melding together like spies let James
[ __ ] bond and magic and what if there
were spies who only used magic never
used [ __ ] guns because what's the
point if you can do magic right and so
there's a my Omega like in my five on my
six whatever in my Omega is the
Directorate of the British intelligence
the defense against magical threats
right and so there's a bunch of [ __ ]
spies who were just like James Bond is
only a handful of them because it's
magic and it's rare but they go off and
they defend the realm against magic
threats I want to see this as do i and
there was a company that was like we
want to see it too and so we like I did
a couple of rewrites for them and I went
up and down the chain and I pitched
everybody until the dude who has to sign
off on it hears like we love it we love
it but we're just not sure you know like
it's I don't like I don't know what to
tell you man like I it is what it is
it's there's things that it can be
there's things that I'm happy to help
trim notice to a place where you think
you can say yes but there's things that
can't be and it's going to be expensive
and you're going to cast Brits and
you're going to be shooting
internationally because if you're not
doing James Bond yeah with magic then
it's not that thing look you can't do
this for the CW
I like the CW lots of CW [ __ ] is fun but
I it it can't be Chuck you know it's
like I'm a globe-trotting spy who's only
ever kind of indoors you know like we
can build this [ __ ] and Morocco on the
Warner Brothers lot because we're never
gonna take him anywhere so we need it
it had scale and it needed to be that
like at some point we're gonna fight a
Chinese dragon because of course we are
like that was the other thing like there
are whole pockets of the world
like magical history and so there's the
gulags of russia that have awful [ __ ]
there was the chinese dragon that runs
the underworld
there's the yeah it was just it still is
awesome it's not gonna be that thing now
it may never be that thing but that's
that's the job right but the joy is you
do own it it's money you can dust that
off anytime you want and when when
tastes are moving in directions and you
can go with it so it's great like it
still belongs to me I never sold it to
anybody I would have liked to because
money's awesome but I did I can't take
Star Wars anywhere else that's just the
truth somebody still owns it I think but
yeah and that the job is you you pour
your heart into a thing and you spend a
year give or take making it the best you
can and then you put it out into the
world and if somebody wants to adopt it
that awesome and if they don't alright
well I made a thing and I have to find a
way to take some solace and some comfort
in that and and take it as far as you
can
like I never feel bad about something
not going if I've done everything I can
do to get it there right like I've
called every person I could call it
pitched every person I can pitch I got
in the room where it happens and it
didn't happen you know and just Whedon
once said something awesome which was he
said my favorite part of making movies
is when I'm writing it because it's
perfect
it's exactly the right cast you're on
time you're on budget because his
imagination is alive and in that and so
the act of writing the pitch and coming
up with the story is is this is the joy
is is is a great way to spend a life
whether it goes forward from that point
forward going back to my initial thing
it's like I wouldn't trade those three
years for anything they were amazing and
that process alone was immeasurable yeah
everything you're right is more wood for
the fire of getting you better yes right
so like even if it doesn't sell even if
it doesn't get you job you are a better
writer for having written than you would
have been it and it's a joy to the act
of creating it is fun in and of itself
it's it's mental surgery it's mental
surgery but but I mean it's it's what we
want to do anyway I am a huge fan of
having written more than I am of
actually well that's a Dorothy Parker
yeah totally yeah III love the down hill
of like at five like we're almost done
and victory [ __ ] laps and then you
like damn it's a blank cursor again and
just are climbing the mountain you have
to base camp let's go to work again and
it's hard one does not simply walk no
one glimpse or screaming into Mordor
well as as a consumer of these these
ideas that you guys have thank you so
much for the entertainment that you
provide we love always thank you come
come get your giant pile of goodies
again if you need a friend to help carry
their tickets under there somewhere so
careful how you guys doing we can
squeeze a minute hey man what's your
name Mike hey Mike how are you nice to
meet you
I just want to ask if you guys had to do
the next DC Black Label what villain
would you choose and how do you tackle
that villain you go first
what villain well he's more of an
antihero you know I I have an idea for a
Swamp Thing one off that I want to do
but I don't want to say it out but it's
I adore like my DC passions
I love Gotham City period so I love the
characters in the villains in Gotham
City I love well Black Label isn't just
villains it's also less God is blood
let's all for the movies because
remember you know Jokers Black Label
like the one walking penis oh that's
what they're calling you yeah oh I don't
know what the villain yeah what would
you do for the next movie like what
standalone oh you a standalone Batman
villain movie well doctor mr. freeze mr.
freeze like I think it has yet to be
done
with with the poetic empathy the way it
was done in the animated series like
like mr. freeze hands down and I think
it could be a plum role for a foreign
actor I think you can really go a
million interesting grounded human
tragic places with that character and
it's still a lot of fun so mr. freeze
even though he is going to be in the
Batman I think there's something really
interesting about penguin I think
especially given that the great Batman
villains are all it's all fun house
mirror versions of Bruce Wayne yeah
right there all refracting and
reflecting a piece of his personality
and warping it out of control and so
penguin is the child of privilege who
doesn't quite understand the reality of
the world around them as does Bruce
Wayne Bruce Wayne comes from vast [ __ ]
fortune and still doesn't quite
understand the punch and crime in the
face is not the most effective way
policing a city and so to look at
penguin as that to look at penguin as
like what if Donald Trump was evil
what do you mean hypothetically speaking
when I listen I can't apparently I can't
just not step in that but the idea that
that unchecked privilege can warp
somebody's morality and what happens to
a technically good person who goes that
bad yeah I think Oswald Cobblepot is
there's there's a fascinating way to
talk about the world we live in today
when you talk about income disparity
when you're talking about the 1% when
you're talking about all that stuff and
then you had Batman to that and you add
Gotham City to that and you
you know that depth and level of crime
to that I think there's a lot of juice
there yep okay Thank You Sherman come
and get your giant pile of [ __ ]
can we do one more bet one more is Brian
what do we have toys well we have
tickets we can I have a question
Brian's got a question hey Brian how are
you hey Mark I know Brian just my name
his name before I asked him hey man
what's your name Brian
mark on an earlier episode you
introduced Todd as someone who's going
to be co-hosting and said that he knew
more about that man than most anyone
else that you named no don't
yeah well I only have a I only have a
question has a comic book fan already
for both of you huh
we know Alan Moore's we know the Frank
Miller's we know the Jeff lobes I'm
curious from the both of you what is
your favorite story that no one talks
about that's a good one no one talks
about I spend most of my time with nerds
draya's trying to guide me into saying a
thing this is pictionary with with drea
oh oh yeah oh yeah but people talk about
white knight white knight is fantastic
have you read white knight no oh oh [ __ ]
oh okay
no white knight is fantastic it's Sean
Murphy who writes and draws it and the
Joker gets rehabbed and and he finds a
way to turn Gotham on Batman
and Batman is kind of hunted and he's
kind of right
he's not wrong if you have to oh it's
really good so that that's that's
terrific I also love court of owls but
people know about that because it was in
Gotham yeah so but the white night is a
tremendous book there was a Riddler book
years ago early I don't say early
two-thousands maybe late 90s there was
like a series of Riddler books I forget
who wrote them but they were called
Riddler oddly enough but yeah white
knight if you haven't read white knight
run it's it's collected in trade by now
you know what ego is good to know nobody
talks about you go the tragedy of Alfred
you know are they don't well that there
is also I can't remember it was an
episode of Batman the Animated Series
I think it was called like the mechanic
yeah about like the dude who fixes Bruce
Batman's car you know the Batmobile yeah
I'm sorry do you know there's the
Batmobile that's what he calls them
what's it called the Batmobile
I gotta do my research only a child
would name it that I love stories about
Batman that don't involve Batman
sometimes because I love the orbit of
that character the gravitational mass
that he has in the in both the DC
Universe and in in Gotham City itself
that his world is bigger than he thinks
it is and there are people in that world
that are that are right for being either
exploited or leveraged or damaged to
force Batman to do different there's a
great Batman story in planetary and
what's awesome about it is
the planetary team they they run through
all these eras of Batman's so at one
point there in the Frank Miller world at
one point there in the Adam West world
West world Adam West world there's
robots that look like this old chum and
it's it's pretty special
it's a pretty special see John Cassaday
who did the art for this yes Warren
Ellis wrote it John Cassidy they loved
to see him channel all of the various
interpretations it's like wires ears so
[ __ ] pointy it's hysterical
yeah I'm currently reading a Batman in
the map the max they've over of a chef
Kieth Batman and the max that's fun yeah
I hope that came close to answering your
question it came all the way and then
some to answer my question good thank
you guys awesome would you like some
tickets to the 40x
so you don't wanted that book yeah we
got no more books I think that's it for
Q&A which means I think that's it for
this episode
what of black man why it flew by why did
you guys have fun tonight I could not
have done this without the gentleman
sitting to my right todd stashwick thank
you thank you for comments be me to
thumb thank you for coming to the black
cave to play with their big shoes to
fill I hope I hope I did his you absence
justice you have acquitted yourself well
okay good
but that is it for this episode of black
man beyond stay tuned two weeks because
the lovely and talented Tricia Helfer
will be standing where Todd stashwick is
right now so yeah her spine glows hers
you know I haven't seen it we're not
that close
little bit of even if you were that
close cuz it's anyway listen man I don't
maybe just doing it wrong
what's the facing away I know okay
[Laughter]
anyway thank you for coming
stay tuned same black time same black
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith good night everybody
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you